herzlich willkommen zurück liebe
zuschauer bei film nachts und wir machen
direkt weiter mit der these von politik
chef jan schäfer ja die zuschauerinnen
und zuschauer die bundesregierung die
ampelkoalition ist noch nicht einmal 100
tage im amt und meiner meinung nach ist
der koalitionsvertrag der abgeschlossen
wurde aber eigentlich nur noch schrott
denn er stammt aus einer anderen zeit
damals im jahr 20 21 war der ukraine
krieg noch relativ weit ferner hatte
immer noch die hoffnung dass putin nicht
so weit gehen würde hier gegangen ist
und dann hat sich überlegt zwischen spd
grünen und fdp so wirklich
herausforderte dinge wie eine ausweitung
der elternzeit viele viele sozial
geschenke beispielsweise auch an die
rentner
bezahlten urlaub zwei wochen bezahlten
urlaub für die junge väter all das soll
der staat soll die allgemeinheit
bezahlen es gibt wahnsinnig viele
förderprogramme auch für klimaschutz der
natürlich total wichtig ist aber auch da
die frage wird das geld immer richtig
eingesetzt ich glaube die
bundesregierung die ampel koalition muss
komplett neu denken der krieg den wir
sehen muss dazu führen dass viele dinge
im haushalt komplett umgeschichtet
werden noch viel stärker hinrichtung
bundeswehr auch richtung verteidigung
und vor allem richtung entlastung der
bürger und entlastung der wirtschaft
denn das was uns hier droht auch durch
den krieg das wird eine neue rezession
vielleicht sogar eine depression sein
das heißt weg mit dem alten
koalitionsvertrag wir brauchen einen
neustart wir brauchen ein völlig neues
papier dame
paul es gibt weniger beziehungsweise
niemanden den ich kenne der
innenpolitisch und außenpolitisch seiner
expertise hat wenn du jetzt jan zugehört
hat bei der t sich hoffe die verbindung
war gut genug er würde dem zustimmen
muss ein neuer koalitionsvertrag her und
falls ja was sollte jetzt auch explizit
mit blick auf den krieg drin stehen
neuer koalitionsvertrag den solltest
geben vor allem sollte es ein
gipfeltreffen geben finde ich zwischen
den drei parteien und da komme ich
sozusagen wieder auf die ursprungs teso
die debatte zurück des embargos ich
glaube dass annalena baerbock und
christian lindner die fdp steht für die
freiheit so zu sagen annalena baerbock
spa tisch dann schon lange für einen
schärferen kurs gegenüber russland dass
die beiden jetzt die verantwortung haben
olaf scholz einzufangen und zu sagen das
machen wir nicht mit nicht länger diese
positionierung nicht länger in unserem
land eine positionierung die dazu führt
dass wir putins kriegskasse füllen und
deswegen ist es völlig richtig ein neuer
koalitionsvertrag und insbesondere ein
gipfeltreffen und zwar sofort wo
christian lindner und annalena baerbock
klar sagen diese politik die ihr
jahrelang mit angela merkel führen
konnte diese politik die geprägt ist aus
putin liebe und aus schröder zeiten die
ist ein für alle mal vorbei und
insbesondere so lange vorbei wie
wladimir putin hier einen grausamen
krieg führt also anna-lena werbe und
christian lindner müssen jetzt olaf
scholz anfangen
also ich finde ich bin jetzt nicht
berater der koalition das muss die
koalition schon selbst entscheiden ob
sie neuen koalitionsvertrag braucht aber
mir wäre es ehrlicher weise lieber sie
würden jetzt in dieser krise sehr
schnell und konsequent handeln wir haben
das gesehen bei den lieferungen die ich
vorhin angesprochen habe wie lange das
gedauert hat wir sehen das wie das mit
der kontaktaufnahme der ukraine dauert
ich muss ihn schon gesagt habe mich
geschämt als ich gesehen habe wie wie
der präsident den ski emanuel makro
gedankt hat und wie wir da gestanden
haben wird wie bedröppelte pudel da
wünsche ich mir das jetzt konkret
gehandelt wird und wir können jetzt viel
darüber diskutieren dass wir ein
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr
brauchen wir können viel darüber
diskutieren dass wir uns auf diese neue
sicherheitslage
einspielen müssen aber mir geht es jetzt
darum dass wir schnellstmöglich den
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer
die jeden tag unter dauerbeschuss dieses
kranken mannes stehen dass wir denen
helfen und in neuer koalitionsvertrag
das kann jetzt auch noch mal ein paar
wochen warten bei aller liebe erobern
aber sie sehen ja auch was dafür wenn
ich eine frage ja
ich habe eine frage an der u-bahn die
mir schon vorher den kopf kam weil sie
gesagt haben dass putin sozusagen weg
muss sind sie der überzeugung wie
lindsay graham der republikanische
abgeordnete nur schade gesagt hat jemand
muss putin erschießen jemand muss putin
ermorden
das ist eine ganz ganz schwierige
geschichte man wünscht glaube ich
niemanden den tod auch wenn in diesen
tagen ein wahnsinniger hass und eine
wahnsinnige wut auf diese person
herrscht ich weiß nicht ob das am ende
das ganze beendet ich sage nur wladimir
putin darf nie wieder einen fuß auf ein
anderes land dieser welt setzen er darf
noch einmal dass ich einmal er darf noch
einmal das design los er darf jetzt
können die sie da sagt hermann zweimal
darf noch ein einziges mal ein anderes
land betreten und das ist in den haag
vor dem internationalen strafgerichtshof
das muss das ziel sein
und ich kann mir das vollkommen ich kann
es vollkommen nachvollziehen dass viele
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer so denken ich
kann es mir auch durchaus vorstellen
dass viele menschen in deutschland so
denken und sagen eigentlich müsste einer
jetzt so wie stauffenberg versucht hat
das ganze auch bei putin tun aber ich
persönlich sage für mich steht die würde
des menschen immer noch an erster stelle
und auch wenn ich diesen hass und diese
wut auf diese person nachvollziehen kann
unser ziel muss es sein dass er am ende
vor dem internationalen strafgerichtshof
in den haag steht
ist die antwort völlig ausreichend war
absolut ich hab' ich habe es verstanden
nur zu sagen dass
wladimir putin also ich meine er
erbringt halt jeden tag menschen um ja
und das passiert halt jetzt in diesem
moment
deswegen ist halt die frage wie ist er
zu stoppen und ich glaube
ja also ich würde da auch die indie
antwort von von anderen melde
interessieren wie er das sieht und wie
er das bewertet was der amerikanische
abgeordnete lindsay graham gesagt
ja es gibt viele optionen und sicher
werden wir das geschehen könnte einen
putsch ganz oben könnte nicht
ausgeschlossen werden denn auch die
clique herum um den boden herum sie kann
auch nicht umhin umzusehen also diesen
freien fall der wirtschaft auch der
gesellschaft und deswegen ein
volksaufstand wäre auch denkbar möglich
aber vielleicht nicht gleich nur wenn
die menschen tatsächlich spüren die
diese folgen der sanktionen
die truppen könnten auch versorgen das
geschieht schon heute man man darf auch
das nicht aus den augen verlieren dass
dass die soldaten die er massenweise in
den tod geschickt in der ukraine sind
nach unseren angaben über 11.000 tote
soldaten die ihr ende im boden der
ukraine gefunden haben ich meine und da
sehen auch die anderen dh es gibt viele
faktoren die jetzt auch eine gewisse
wirkung entfalten könnten und um diesen
krieg zu beenden aber für uns für mich
ist wichtig und ich darf vielleicht ganz
kurz zurück zum thema koalitionsvertrag
zurückkommen es steht dort im dokument
ein thema eu und der ukraine sehr
schwierig formuliert und heute das
wissen wir mein präsident salewski wo
ich jetzt immer noch in kiew ist er hat
nicht nur jetzt waffen um waffen gebeten
er hat auch das thema auf den tisch
gelegt dass die ukraine zumindest jetzt
diese eu-weites perspektive bekommt und
wir hoffen dass die deutschen das
unterstützen die ampel regierung stemmt
sich leider also die antworten bis heute
war können wir nicht machen und das kann
doch nicht sein dass dem land dass der
bond wird tag und nacht wo menschen
fliehen müssen hoffentlich nur vorläufig
auch nach deutschland das diesem land
diese perspektive weggenommen wird dass
die menschen die fliehen die brauchen
eine zukunft die brauchen zuversicht
dass sie auch bald zurückkommen und
dieses land gemeinsam aufbauen darum
geht es und deswegen wollen wir auch die
deutschen appellieren die unterstützen
diese idee eine mehrheit der deutschen
wäre auch dafür dass die ukraine nicht
heute und nicht in fünf jahren aber
vielleicht in zehn jahren auch teil
dieser familie wird darum geht es und
das ist ganz ganz wichtig es wird viel
über die frage des eu-beitritts
gesprochen es geht nicht darum dass die
ukraine von heute auf morgen einfach so
teil der europäischen union ist sondern
es geht darum die beitrittsverhandlungen
zu starten kleines perspektive wir haben
auch die europäische union es geht jetzt
auch luca ihn geht ja das muss man
leider sagen auch als ein korruptes land
ist sie bereits union also wir haben
begonnen unsere hausaufgaben im jahre
2014 zu machen wir haben einen
assoziierungsabkommen und ich war in der
regierung ein jahr lang nach dem mann
und meine einzige aufgabe bestand darin
damit dass die ukrainische behörden
dieses dokument das ist
1200 seiten dick dass wir das umsetzen
wir sind ziemlich gut im
plan im zeitplan wenn wir bis zum jahre
25 wie es steht fertig sind dann stünden
wir nicht schlecht oder sogar besser da
als die letzten kandidaten länder
rumänien und bulgarien die beigetreten
sind das heißt wir machen unsere
hausaufgaben das ist nicht so dass wir
irgendwo ganz hinten in der reihe stehen
und plötzlich nach vorne wollen nein wir
wissen worum es geht es kommt darauf an
dass diese politische entscheidung heute
gleich in berlin getroffen wird und dann
dieser weg der verhandlungsweg geöffnet
wird und dann werde ich schauen wenn sie
scheitern dann haben wir keine chance
wenn wir wenn wir erfolge zeigen wir
jetzt in diesem krieg wo wir bestehen wo
wir die menschen auf der ganzen welt
überrascht haben mit dem mut mit der
erfolgreich wir könnten auch die
europäer auf die deutschen auch die
ampel überraschen dass wir auch da ganz
schnell vorankommen können ich finde ja
nicht aber schenkt noch kurz am ende
muss man wirklich sagen die ukraine ist
in einer ganz besonderen situation wie
wir es seit vielen vielen jahrzehnten
auf europäischem boden nicht erlebt
haben und deswegen muss man ihn jetzt
eine perspektive bieten ich weiß dass
das auch bei mir in meiner partei sehr
kontrovers diskutiert aber ich halte es
für richtig es geht und das hat der
botschaft eben gerade noch mal sehr
deutlich gesagt es geht nicht darum
heute zu entscheiden ist die ukraine
mitglied in der europäischen union
sondern starten wir ein prozess der in
den nächsten fünf oder zehn jahren ab
und das wäre ein starkes zeichen was von
berlin aus gesendet werden muss und ich
kann das zögern der ampel an dieser
stelle nicht verstehen und damit würde
ich sagen kommen wir direkt sich aber
gemischt
ich frage mich eine sache wie kann wie
canon irgendein politiker in dieser
regierung in deutschland ist noch mit
dem gewissen vereinbaren diese dinge
abzulegen
schauen doch auch nachrichten die sehen
doch die bilder zu sehen doch was wir
berichten und wie kann man denn der
ukraine in so einer phase verweigern er
zumindest zu rücken an die europäische
union noch mal wenige kilometer hier wo
ich gerade bin entfernt haben 2014 die
menschen mit einer europäischen flagge
demonstriert und diese menschen da
demonstriert haben die sind jetzt an der
front und die sind dort an der front
weil sie europäische werte verteidigt
und was machen unsere politiker die
sagen naja mal abwarten man darf den
putin nicht provozieren schauen wir mal
ich hab da kaum noch worte für
das geht genau darum und sammer man darf
putin nicht mit der angst begegnen wenn
deutsche außenpolitik wenn europäische
außenpolitik oder außenpolitik des
westens nur mit der angst vorangeht dann
kann man am ende wladimir putin nicht
besiegen das ist die wahrheit und
deswegen müssen wir wieder zu
selbstbewusstsein zu stärken kommen als
europäer als westen insgesamt das
wünsche ich mir eigentlich das putze ich
auch in der nächsten generation